president biden facing calls from the
media to quit before he does even more
damage to the country and his party i'm
laughing at craig as biden recovers from
covet liberals are sensing a golden
opportunity to hit the guy while he's
down and find someone better to replace
him and boy biden's down the latest
quinnipiac poll is joe's approval rating
at another all-time low just 31
and now the washington post is giving
the green light to this
quit joe quit
biden could save the midterms with a
one-term pledge
chris christie summing up the
president's situation this way
when 64
of your own party says a year and a half
into your presidency thanks but no
thanks um that does reflect i agree with
you the frustrations of democrats some
because they don't think he's done
enough
and some because they think he's done
too much joe biden is in no man's land
that's an awful place to be as an office
holder when you don't have anybody as
the president finds himself in more
political peril he's also running out of
allies all he has left is his dopey
chief of staff ron klain who offered
this lame explanation for the plummeting
polls watch i think the president's
approval rating is kind of a reflection
of how people feel about what's going on
in the country and some things in our
country aren't going well
not because of what the president did
but in fact because of what the
president's fighting against
all right before i ask you if you buy
ron clayton's spin what did you think of
the msnbc host's outfit
jesse
you asking me i am
i'm not asking greg well you know what i
got to tell you you could make comments
on my outfit too
all right look i'll tell you what i
think about ron clayne though i mean
when the guy actually says the people
are not disappointed in joe biden
they're disappointed in the country
yeah okay it's not joe are you kidding i
mean when 18
what is this 71 of the americans don't
want this guy to run again he's only a
year and a half into his presidency i
mean you know
you can try to spin it any way you want
you can tell the american people don't
believe your lion eyes it's better than
you think it is the truth is when you go
to buy gas when you go to the
supermarket when you go to buy baby
formula when you think about people in
afghanistan when you talk about your
neighbor whose kid's got a drug problem
and then you think about what's going on
coming through the southern border the
fact that the word fentanyl has never
come out of joe biden's mouth this guy
is totally clueless to what's going on
in this country and so you know what
they can try to cover it up and and and
sugarcoat it any way they want
americans know how they feel they know
what they see and they got it right
christie's interpretation of joe being
in no man's land greg so he's saying and
then people who don't like him because
he's not done enough and then the rest
of the party doesn't like him because he
hasn't done
he's done too much see this is i think
this is a mistake uh to frame it this
way because if you're saying that the
left hates you and the moderates hate
you that's could be a compliment for a
democrat you know what i'm saying
because you're an equal opportunist when
it comes to disappointing people but it
could just be that he's really bad you
know uh
if by you know the mark of a good movie
is you can you know it's a good movie
within the first 10 minutes and the
biden presidency is like a bad movie so
you sit down and within 10 minutes
you're going oh my god this is not what
we expected and you can at least you can
leave the movie unfortunately you can't
leave this movie you're stuck here but
the more that the dems deny biden the
more i say he should get four more years
because that's
because the more you know what because
that's what the dems do with republicans
they they seized upon the most
vulnerable candidates in races right and
they try to you know
beg them up or what do you call them
pick them up and egg it on why don't
that's what the republicans would do
they should they should want to to run
against biden but the discontent the
discontent is getting louder because
january 6 floundered it ended up
accidentally exonerating trump they
showed no planned coup no criminality
they had to move the goal post into the
parking lot now it's like oh he he took
too long
fine why is it that he seems more
electable now it's like is it because
the public saw that it was a show trial
and that they didn't sympathize they
actually sympathized with the other side
then with the
with the congress they just saw them as
a bunch of drama queens so this is a
teachable moment you know when trump
looks better than biden after three
weeks of non-stop political action prop
then that that says something about your
candidate the guy's less less popular
than chronic halitosis he stinks
jessica
to greg's point about the the movie
concept
usually presidencies have like peaks and
valleys you know trump's was kind of
like that you know things would be
really bad and then he'd kill a big
terrorist you know he'd be impeached and
then you know he he'd be acquitted it
was kind of good
not even at the third act yet right but
joe biden since he came in has just gone
down down farther and farther
afghanistan the border both delta waves
he gets coveted he falls off his bike
everything has just gone down has he
done anything well so far well i know
democrats are most upset about falling
off his bike that was really when we
said this guy has got to go symbolic can
i get the uh twice impeached uh
you know kova denier and the beginning
guy back in office um a lot of points
were made
i want to try to address them first on
the january 6th committee not a show
trial we even had the wall street
journal and the new york post saying
that trump was unelectable again that it
was dereliction of duty he sat by and
watched this for hours and he was the
one who streets were about but of course
it is what the hearings are about no it
was about finding some kind of criminal
responsibility we haven't even fight
about it
that's right that'll happen in september
right no but there are people who are
arguing the october there are
conservatives who are arguing that they
have seen it anyway they're the same
people joe biden is very unpopular
ron clean you can just say his poll
numbers are bad that's fine because
there is actually good news which is
that democrats if you look at what's
happening on the congressional ballot
are inching up and up and up so now it's
not a wave election it's a competitive
election we've seen nato's
yes and our own fox polling team has
come up with that ceo foxx
right actually some of the best
pollsters in the industry are here at
fox so nate silver nate cohn dave
wasserman have all shifted their
analyses towards us we have three new
gop polls that came out within the last
few days chamber of commerce echelon
insights and americans for prosperity
all had democrats up three to five
points now i'm not saying we don't lose
the house but there is certainly a
chance that we only lose a few seats i
think our bottom rating is losing seven
seats um the fox rating from the
pollsters here um and keeping the senate
and that's a pretty great income outcome
for a midterm all right you want to put
some money on that
how much how much you make a lot more
than me okay 100
100
look democrats are trying to get rid of
joe biden in 2024 because they think
he's going to lose against pretty much
any republican president especially
president donald trump if he runs joe
biden is less popular now than president
trump was and he has nowhere to go from
here he's a lame duck president his
agenda is dead before the midterms and
what democrats are offering is not
someone like a joe manchin to replace
biden in 2024 who is a more moderate who
is reflective of the country as a
democrat and just as an american they
want someone like gavin newsom who was
at the white house when joe biden was
overseas he just like snuck right in
there to have a meeting with ron clayne
and that just like everything was fine
there was no other agenda other than
what was going on in california they're
not looking for someone who is more
moderate than joe biden they're looking
for someone who is even further to the
left if they were smart what would
happen is joe biden if when republicans
do win the house maybe the senate
they would work with him like bill
clinton did and he could revive his
presidency after republicans take over
given the way that wrong claim is around
the white house i doubt that's going to
happen the other thing is
that they're redefining of the word
recession i mean it's like they redefine
words and think that it just doesn't
exist and it's like every american knows
that we're in a recession they're all
saving money for a recession eighty
percent ninety percent of the country is
affected by high gas prices which the
administration is doing on purpose so
this idea that they can just say well it
doesn't technically mean this they're
completely out of touch with what people
are feeling and just redefining the word
or not mentioning it isn't going to
change everybody's status with the
economy
and they clearly have no policy position
that they're going to change either
yeah i'm going to start redefining words
but woman's already been you have to
learn the words first oh you got me
there greg
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now